Je suis heureuse avec toi.
Moi aussi,
je suis heureux avec toi.
Je t’aime.
Ah, euh …
Merci.
Alors, ça,
c’est une règle ancestrale.
Quand on te dit «Je t’aime»,
tu réponds jamais par «merci».
Tous les êtres humains de la planète
se sont réunis dans une pièce pour se dire
«Ok, on dit pas merci».
- Non, ça m’étonnerai.
je sais pas, elle m’a sorti ça
comme ça, moi je …
je m’y attendais pas.
Mais ça fait 4 mois que tu mets
ta langue dans sa bouche,
qu’est-ce que tu voulais
qu’elle te dise?
Et puis c’est pas bien grave,
t’es amoureux toi aussi, non?
Oui. Mais le dire,
c’est toujours un peu une étape.
Non, c’est un truc naturel.
Moi à chaque fois que je couche avec une meuf,
je lui dis «Je t’aime».
C’est au moment de l’orgasme,
je peux pas m’en empêcher.
C’est-à-dire? Pile pile au moment,
ou juste après …?
C’est un peu des deux, c’est...
(Bruits Bizarres)
«Je t’aime!»
Voilà.
Ok, on peut revenir à mon histoire?
-Oui,
donc tu lui as dit «Merci»?
Et...
Non mais Laure, reste,
c’est pas ce que je voulais dire.
C’est bon, ça va,
t’embête pas.
Non mais merci,
c’était gentil de ta part.
Oh c’est pas vrai.
C’est pas si facile.
-Pas si facile? C’est trois mots!
Non, c’est plus deux mots et demi,
si tu regardes bien,
«T apostrophe»,
pas vraiment un mot, donc …
Bon ok, c’est deux mots et demi.
C’est quand même le truc
le plus facile du monde!
Vous êtes marrants là,
je l’ai jamais dit à aucune meuf.
Mais tu leur dis quoi du coup?
"Je t’aime."
Moi aussi.
Carrément.
Tu trouves pas que
ça va un peu vite là?
Ce que tu viens de dire là,
la même chose.
C’est vraiment la meilleure nouv …
Ok, c’est nul.
Tu veux pas faire un test VIH avant?
Ou n’importe quelle autre
MST hein?
A l’identique.
Ah ouais, quand même.
Enfin bref,
pour en revenir à Laure,
elle est rentrée chez elle hier soir
et là j’ai plus de nouvelles.
Bon ben écoute, t’inquiètes pas,
déjà on va commander à manger
Et à boire!
-Et à boire,
et on va trouver une solution.
Et puis si on la trouve pas,
on picolera jusqu’à ce qu’on oublie.
C’est sympa les gars,
merci.
C’est normal mon gars,
on t’aime.
Moi aussi je vous aime.
AHHHH
Je t’aime.
Tu m’as dit «Je t’aime»?
Ouais mais je crois que
je pensais à un pote …